[Music]  Meryl Streep plants a celebratory kiss  on Robert De Niro ladies and gentlemen a  National Board of Review Best Actress  for the 68 year old star looked divine  accepting her award for Best Actress for  her work in the post at the National  Board of Review annual awards gala in  New York on Tuesday it's always  gratifying to receive approbation from  knowledgeable people her longtime pal  and falling in love co-star Robert De  Niro had the honor of introducing Meryl  74 year-old Robert delivered a sweet  speech praising Niro both on and off  screen Meryl thank you for speaking out  on matters of conscience that affected  all of us Streep showed her gratitude  for Roberts touching words with a hug  and big kiss on the lips it's very  exciting  it's so great that the NBR is honoring  us tonight because Steven Spielberg has  created a masterpiece and and I'm so  proud of the film and I'm so proud of  the amazing cast  you